hallo ihr lieben ich hab gerade besuch
aus der türkei und habe mir gedacht was
kann man denn gleich leckeres zum
milchkaffee essen machen wir eine
leckere torte mit vier sich locker
leichten quaken und dem blitz biscuit
boden denn viel zeit möchte ich ja hier
nicht verbringen in der küche und wir
können direkt starten mit dem blitz
bizkit boden
dafür benötigen wir zwei eier warmes
wasser zucker mehl backpulver und um
etwas geschmack reinzukriegen noch den
abtrieb einer limette oder einer bio
zitrone den backofen habe ich jetzt
schon vorgeheizt auf 180 grad ober und
unterhitze und wir gehen jetzt die eier
in die küchenmaschine zusammen mit zwei
esslöffel waren leitungswasser
und jetzt wird das ganze auf höchster
stufe also ungefähr 23 minuten ein
bisschen cremig gerührt dann kommt
zucker hinzu und dann weitere fünf
minuten cremig rühren
insgesamt brauchen wir so ungefähr acht
minuten
[Musik]
die masse ist richtig schön dick cremig
geworden die mit habe ich auch mit dazu
gegeben den abtrieb und zwar die halbe
denn die andere hälfte gibt es gleich
noch mit dem die creme und jetzt
verrühren wir mehl mit backpulver und
sieben das dann auch noch in einem
schwung mit der 1
so die trockenen zutaten sind jetzt drin
und jetzt wird das so lange verrührt bis
das miteinander verbunden ist also nicht
zu lange unsere bizkit masse ist auch
schon fertig und ich für sie jetzt um in
meine 24 cm springform mit backpapier
ausgelegten ansonsten nicht gefettet ihr
könnt auch eine 26 cm springform nehmen
aber größer würde ich dann auch nicht
gehen denn sonst wird der boden zu dünn
[Musik]
nachdem der teig dann glatt verstrichen
wurde kommt in den vorgeheizten backofen
bei 180 grad ober und unterhitze main
taipeh sind noch im ofen und solange der
ofen noch warm ist werde ich jetzt schon
mal die 40 gäste zubereiten und dafür
brauchen wir auch noch ganz wenige
standard zutaten und zwar ein ei mehl
etwas backpulver neutrales ölig ab
sonnenblumenöl genommen außerdem zucker
und irgendwann auch um eurer wahl zum
beispiel zitronenschalen abrieb oder
wandeln der extrakt ganz wie ihr möchtet
und hierfür brauchen wir keine
küchenmaschine ich hier bin zuallererst
das alles zusammen mit dem zucker in
eine schüssel und ruhe das ganz einfach
mit dem schneebesen jetzt habe ich eine
minute lang fleißig gerührt und das ist
so ein bisschen cremiger geworden und
jetzt geben wir in einem dünnen strahl
unserer neutrales öl dazu und dabei
immer fleißig weiter rühren
an der schule gebe ich jetzt noch mal
zitronenaroma mit rein
die debatte könnte doch vanille zucker
vanille extrakt was auch immer alles was
ihr am liebsten mögen gerne und dann
geben wir noch mehl und backpulver dazu
und das sieben wir damit auch keine
klümpchen entstehen
[Musik]
in schleesen gebe ich jetzt zur seite
und jetzt macht ihr mit euren sauberen
händen weiter ganz einfach zu einem teig
verkneten und wundert euch nicht der
teig wird etwas klebrig sein aber das
ist genau richtig so
[Musik]
der keks teig ist jetzt fertig ich war
mir jetzt einfach die kühe zeit also ich
lief jetzt nicht in den kühlschrank für
eine halbe stunde
ihr könntet es tun dann ist es
vielleicht ein bisschen leichter zu
rollen aber ich habe so keine
schwierigkeiten denn ich werde mir jetzt
die hände einfach zu feucht mit ein
bisschen bei leitungswasser und dann
nehme ich mir einen teelöffel und stelle
mir da immer so eine kleine kugel
abreise dann und dann gebe ich sie auch
mal mit backpapier ausgelegtes backblech
[Musik]
und so kommen sie jetzt in den backofen
der ist ja schon vorgeheizt bei gleicher
hitze also 180 grad ungefähr acht bis
zehn minuten sie dürfen nicht braun
werden also sie müssen noch richtig
schön hell bleiben das ist wichtig ich
zeige euch gleich noch das endergebnis
und meinen bis gebunden ist in der
zwischenzeit nämlich fertig geworden das
nicht auskühlen und zeigen euch dann
auch gleich nach genau acht minuten sind
meine kekse so aus die risse sind völlig
in ordnung und ganz normal wenn man sich
umsieht sind sich ganz leicht braun
wichtig ist dass die an der oberfläche
noch richtig schön hell sind hier zeige
ich euch jetzt auch mein bis geboten
denn habe jetzt hier mit einem
küchentuch abgedeckt und lasse ihn
vollständig auskühlen für die
weiterverarbeitung der kekse benötigen
wir marmelade eurer wahl
außerdem zwei behälter mit etwas
leitungswasser und da gebe ich noch
lebensmittelfarbe rein einmal etwas
gelbe lebensmittelfarbe und etwas rote
und jetzt kommt der absolut spaßigste
teil ich liebe das wir nehmen uns jetzt
zwei kekse die aufeinander passen also
ungefähr gleich groß sind dann werden
sie mit marmelade bestrichen und dann
gucken wir sie in die flüssigkeit mit
lebensmittelfarbe an der effekt ist
wunderbar richtig hübsch
jetzt habe ich den code zur hälfte in
gelb und zur anderen hälfte in rot
eingefärbt aber nicht ganz so schwer
dass er noch ein bisschen individuell
aussehen und damit das jetzt noch mal so
richtig schön 40 effekt bekommt wenn wir
das jetzt noch ganz leicht in weißen
kristallzucker
[Musik]
meine 40 cookies sind jetzt im
kühlschrank bis zur weiterverarbeitung
wir machen jetzt die leckere quarkcreme
ich zeige euch jetzt als meine freunde
wie zutaten dass es einmal magerquark
ihr könnt ihr auch gerne den 20 oder 40
prozentigen nehmen außerdem kalte
schlagsahne etwas schmand ihr könnt
wahlweise auch creme fraiche oder aber
saure sahne nehmen dann habe ich hier
weiße kuvertüre die habe ich bereits 15
minuten lang abkühlen lassen
außerdem seine stand mittel dann nehme
ich noch den rest meiner bio limette und
zwar den abrieb der schale und noch ein
paar 4 sicher aus der dose zuallererst
schlage ich die sahne jetzt steigt die
ist ganz frisch aus dem kühlschrank die
muss absolut kalt sein
und da gebe ich jetzt zwei teelöffel
seine stand mittel mit rein dann wird es
aber ganz kurz steif geschlagen
[Musik]
so die sahne ist fertig die gebe ich
jetzt bis zur weiterverarbeitung in den
kühlschrank oder machen wir mit den
anderen zutaten weiter als nächstes
nehmen uns eine große schüssel und geben
da magerquark und schmand mit hinein und
dann wird das einmal gut verrührt
die beiden zutaten habe ich jetzt gerade
so ein paar sekunden miteinander
verrührt und jetzt gebe ich den abrieb
der limette noch mit rein so schmeckt
richtig frisch und später die
kombination aus weißer schokolade und
limette ein traum
und als nächstes geben wir die weiße
schokolade in einem dünnen strahl
reinlassen den mixer ganz langsam laufen
und verrühren das miteinander wichtig
ist hier noch der hinweis dass die
schokolade wirklich total kalt ist also
sie ist auch nicht lauwarm denn
ansonsten würde euch das gerät und
achtet einfach drauf dass sie dann nicht
hart wird sondern einfach schön flüssig
bleibt
[Musik]
als nächstes kommt unser sand stand
mittel mit rein wird auch noch mal kurz
untergerührt und dann heben wir die
sahne und kann dann ist unsere creme
eigentlich auch schon fertig
zoe liebe zählt unsere leckere torte
endlich befüllt und zwar mit unseren
leckeren 40 hälften außerdem unserer
creme die schon fertig ist und hier habe
ich unseren tortenboden hier habe ich
noch einen runden back rahmen drum herum
gelegt und jetzt gebe ich erstmal eine
dünne schicht von der creme darüber auf
die dünne schicht creme verteilen wir
jetzt alle unsere vier sich hier und
dann gehen wir den kompletten rest der
creme obendrauf und streichen das noch
mal schön glatt
[Musik]
so die torte isst befüllt und glatt
verstrichen und jetzt muss sie noch
gekühlt werden aber nicht zu lange
eineinhalb bis zwei stunden reichen
vollkommen in der milch sahne stand
mittel sondern auch die weiße kuvertüre
die nach dem erkälten einfach fest wird
also grandios bis gleich und nach der
kür zeit können wir den tortenring
entfernen die torte ist richtig schön
fest geworden und dann dekorieren wie
sie ich habe jetzt noch man hingenommen
gehackte und gerüstete ich habe sie
anschließend abkühlen lassen nach dem
löschvorgang und dann an den rand
gegeben ich finde es gibt noch mal so
schön krank und sieht auch gut aus ihr
könnt ihr auch zum beispiel kokosnüsse
nehmen oder alles was sehen möchte
und ansonsten habe ich noch die ganzen
seine truppe außenrum macht einfach
seine aufgeschlagen mit sahne stand
mittel und die kuckucke kekse die physik
so umgeben wünscht sich einander und ihr
merkt schon ein bisschen ich bin schon
bisschen hibbelig weil ich die ganz
gerne mal probieren möchte heute mensch
vor der kamera weil wir das jetzt unten
mit der familie genießen aber ich werde
euch auf jeden fall noch fotos vom
anschnitt einblenden
[Musik]
und wir gehen die torte jetzt zusammen
mit der familie und dem besuch genießen
unglaublich lecker sind die einzelnen
schichten lasst euch jetzt mal ganz kurz
auf die zunge zergehen einen bizkit
boden mit einer limetten note dann die
leckeren 4 sicher drin und die
quarkcreme die sowieso mein highlight
ist mit der weißen schokolade zusammen
total lecker und absolut und ob diese
ganzen 40 copies super lecker und ich
finde so ein richtiger hingucker und
seid mal ehrlich so lange hat das gar
nicht gedauert
also das war gar nicht so zeitaufwendig
trotzdem sieht es supertoll aus ich
wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen die genauen mengenangaben
schon unten in der infobox und lass mir
gerne ein abo da damit ihr nichts mehr
verpasst hinterlassen wir gerne einen
kommentar mit einem feedback darüber
freue ich mich immer sehr
und dann sage ich bis zum nächsten mal
auf die gis kitchen tschüss
[Musik]